[Musique]
waouh
donnez-moi le bâton
mais là je m'appelle mandjou oui
j'habite à barque on dit dans la région
de chitral coûte
il faut tenir le bâton comme ça hollande
aller et c'est encore une fois on vient
comme ça fera mais qui était celle là
qu'ils ont fermé la porte et quand j'ai
commencé à crier ils m'ont bâillonné
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle ritoo je vis avec les
membres du gang des saris roses
j'ai appris comment vivre et comment
nous les femmes devenant esclaves
après je me suis approché de lui par
derrière et je lui ai donné un bon coup
de pied comme ça ce jour là nous avons
déclaré que personne ne battrait plus
jamais sa femme
si nous avons des problèmes et que
personne ne nous écoute nous irons
certainement les voir tous tentent pas
monsieur continuera à se battre
les rêves et touahri tous nos fans après
tout tu continueras à te battre
on est avec toi rittaud on a la victoire
est tout ouïe rittaud
[Musique]
on
peu de gens d'inde sont aussi célèbres
quels personnages des films et de
documentaires
lauréate de prix internationaux elle
s'appelle sentent pas de pale ale et la
chef du gang des saris roses
la violence à l'égard des femmes est un
grand problème en inde
les cas les plus graves et les plus
médiatisées ont provoqué des émeutes
une affaire de viol collectif à delhi en
2012 a par exemple vraiment suscité
l'indignation dans tout le pays
[Musique]
sentent pas de pâles cherche à résoudre
ce problème elle ne peut changer la
législation ou donnés à la police
l'ordre de mener des raids
elle est d'une manière différente elle
voyage à travers le pays pour rencontrer
les gens les écouter leur parler je
m'appelle mandjou j'habite à part contre
10 dans la région de chitral coûte sans
elle
j'ai passé mon baccalauréat je viens
d'une famille très pauvre
donc ça a été dur de bénéficier d'une
formation sur un drap dwivedi un homme
qui habite à côté m'a agressé un jour
dans un champ après ça je suis allé chez
lui et je me suis plaint auprès de ses
parents ensuite il a commencé à me faire
du chantage il me disait qu'il m'aimait
qu'il me soutiendrait en compte à la
mosquée est un fait mais abbey il m'a
convaincu et je les cruches
nous avons commencé à être de plus en
plus proche
on sent jusqu'à avoir une intimité
physique un peu plus tard je suis tombée
enceinte sans pattes pas l'entente des
histoires de ce genre ou pire à chaque
réunion avec les membres du gang des
saris roses ici yep asseyez-vous
[Musique]
pas apporté ton bâton l'année ma fille
prend le bâton prend le bateau ma fille
ramasse le comme ta soeur tu pourrais en
avoir besoin
si ta belle mère commence à te faire du
mal un bateau est toujours utile pour
aller chanter aussi c'est une très belle
chanson ça pourrait passer pour la
réunion des membres d'une secte mais en
réalité on y enseigne des choses tout à
fait banal les femmes viennent
principalement avec leurs problèmes de
la vie quotidienne soit joyeux plus fort
je m'appelle s'empale dans le monde
entier on me connaît comme leader du
gang des saris roses
j'ai créé cette organisation le gang des
saris roses à 20 ans avec cinq autres
femmes de la ville
mais il y avait un homme qui bat et
constamment sa femme une fois je lui a
demandé pourquoi l abattée et il m'a dit
je vous rappelle j'avais 20 ans à
l'époque
c'est une très vieille histoire bref il
m'a insulté alors je les battues dans un
champ avec quatre autres femmes
je ne leur ai pas dit qu'il m'avait
insulté quand je lui ai demandé de ne
pas battre sa femme
ces femmes sont tout simplement aller
dans le champ avec moi pour couper
l'herbe mais quand il a quitté son
chambre je me suis approché de lui par
derrière et je lui ai donné un coup de
pied comme ça ensuite j'ai appelé ces
femmes et je leur ai tout raconté et
nous l'avons bien battu ce jour là nous
avons déclaré que personne ne battrait
plus jamais sa femme
c'était le début nous avons commencé à 5
et maintenant on ne sent plus d'un
million
[Musique]
bon maintenant c'est quand je lui ai dit
c'est ton enfant dis moi comment on
l'appellera coup il faut qu'on se marie
dans un ballon au tribunal ou dans un
temple pour que notre mariage soit
officielle il a commencé à m'expliquer
que les tribunaux et d'autres
organisations ne fonctionnait pas à
cause du confinement et que même les
temples été fermés donc c'était
impossible de le faire tout de suite
mais qu'on allait certainement se marier
et il ne faisait rien j'en étais déjà à
mon quatrième mois de grossesse et je
continuais de lui dire que nous devions
nous marier puis il s'est mis à dire
qu'il fallait faire une échographie
j'ai fait ce qu'il m'a demandée
l'échographie a montré un enfant de
quatre mois
je les appelais depuis l'hôpital mais
son téléphone était débranché quand je
suis rentré chez moi je suis allé chez
souviendra pour savoir où il était son
père a dit nous ne savons pas où il est
chercheur de toi même et son oncle
hommes dwivedi qui est elle a commencé à
se fâcher à m'insulter et il m'a demandé
pourquoi j'étais venu il a dit ne sais
tu pas que nous sommes des brahmanes
nous sommes supérieurs à vous nous vous
abattre on est il a commencé à
m'insulter très vulgairement six ans pat
pas le diriger une bande d'hommes
le gouvernement aurait des raisons de
s'inquiéter des billets d'adeptes en
uniforme dans tout le pays
armés de bâtons de combat traditionnel
mais la chef du gang des saris roses
d'enseigner aux indiennes que l'auto des
forces au sein du gang des saris roses
nous apprenons à manier le bateau
on ne rit pas et du riz trop ici tout le
monde est heureux c'est notre combat
nous devons nous battre pour nos droits
vous exiger le respect de vos droits
c'est ce qu'il faut faire ici il y à 250
à 300 personnes en ce moment mais nous
sommes environ 500 en tout beaucoup nous
ont rejoints et beaucoup d'autres sont
prêts à nous rejoindre nous sommes allés
voir les autorités à douchapt naema
second mais personne ne veut nous
écouter
personne ne veut donner leurs droits ou
pauvres le bateau c'est notre arme mais
parfois nous utilisons des chaussures
quand le bateau ne marche pas on utilise
des chaussures nous apprenons aux femmes
a visé le cou de son adversaire avec les
chaussures et parfois même les étrangler
sentent pas de pâles n'est pas féministe
ou militante des droits des femmes au
sens occidental du terme
sa sagesse vient de la population elle
apprend à ses soldats des astuces qui
peuvent être utilisés dans la vie
quotidienne comment par exemple utiliser
la force de l'adversaire contre lui
d'abord cd puis repoussé à l'épaté en
passant un mari et sa femme ne font
qu'un comme une voiture à quatre roues
si une roue ne marche pas comment la
voiture avance rethel voilà pourquoi un
mari et sa femme doivent toujours garder
un équilibre si le mari pense que sa
femme est mauvaise il doit essayer de la
comprendre
moi aussi j'ai une maison une famille je
ne fais pas ça parce que j'ai personnes
à la maison ritoo continue à te battre
on avec paris-tours et tout continue à
te battre
on est avec toi ritoo ritoo continue à
on est avec toi ritoo voilà ritoo tu
montreras ce bateau à ta belle mère
comme ça
une mineure qui a été victime d'un viol
collectif dans le nord de l'inde est
décédé des suites de ses blessures dans
un hôpital de new delhi
[Musique]
selon les statistiques en inde sur cent
mille femmes 16 villes subissent des
violences domestiques
cependant la plupart des problèmes pour
lesquels on vient voir sentent pas de
pâles ne sont pas liées à la violence
mais aux problèmes quotidiens à la
famille par exemple si le mari est
alcoolique et met engage la maison
familiale
voilà le type de problème qui pousse les
femmes à venir vers elle n'aie pas peur
n'aie jamais peur prends soin de toi
l'essentiel est de construire une
famille à donna vie qu'est ce qu'il veut
qu'est ce qu'il veut il a très peur de
vous de moi à oui je pourrais lui donner
une bonne raclée
[Musique]
j'ai appris comment vivre comment les
femmes deviennent esclaves et comment
lutter pour mes droits
voilà ce que j'ai appris oui j'étais à
l'école mais avant je ne le savais pas
je ne comprenais pas je vivais comme une
esclave ont traité comme une servante et
le gang des saris roses m'a appris que
j'avais des droits quand j'ai rejoint le
gang des saris roses
mes parents étaient très heureux à
l'idée que je connaisse enfin mes droits
et que je vive en paix chez moi toute ma
famille et tous mes proches étaient très
heureux 1 oui bien sûr depuis que j'ai
rencontré sent pas de pâles je me sens
en sécurité
jamais
quand j'avais 15 ans ma famille m'a
agacé parfois il n'aimait pas que je
parle de mes droits tant menti à
l'époque les hommes étaient au centre de
la société
maintenant ça va mieux
avant une femme ne pouvait même pas
quitter sa maison une belle mère pouvait
ne pas donner à manger à sa belle fille
elle contrôlait ce qu'elle mangeait
pourquoi les femmes en inde sont elles
si arriérés aujourd'hui parce qu'elles
n'ont jamais eu la possibilité de suivre
une formation et sans formation
elles ne peuvent pas être indépendante
et si elles ne sont pas indépendants
elles ne peuvent pas être libres
elles ne peuvent pas gagner leur propre
pain tout ce qui arrive aux femmes en
inde est dû à l'absence de l'éducation
c'était une tradition de ne pas éduquer
les filles
donc nous les filles et si on jalouse
des sommes qu'ils pouvaient faire des
études
nous allions dans les champs en cachette
pour apprendre des choses à l'ombre des
arbres
j'ai appris à lire et à écrire à c'est
tout je me suis mariée à l'âge de 12 ans
imaginez 12 ans et à 15 ans j'ai
accouché de ma première fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque leader a besoin d'un assistant de
confiance dans le cas du gang des saris
roses
il serait logique de voir une femme aux
côtés de samba de pâles mais son bras
droit est un homme qu'elle a un jour été
[Musique]
mais je m'appelle si arabe hajaba dit
j'habite dans le district de banda alors
mais c'est la maison que j'ai reçu de
mes ancêtres ni ma mère et mon père ont
vécu ici
puis il ya eu des problèmes des gens ont
battu et parents et les ont chassés de
la maison c'était il ya très longtemps
en 1981 j'ai longtemps cherché l'endroit
où mes parents avaient vécu car j'ai
besoin de cette maison bon je suis allé
dans de nombreux endroits
j'ai saisi de nombreux bureaux du
gouvernement j'ai expliqué ma situation
ma position partout mais ça n'a pas aidé
je n'ai reçu aucune aide du gouvernement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai refusé d'avorter
j'ai dit que ça fait mettre ma vie en
danger kébé l'oncle de mon fiancé a
insisté en disant que rien ne
m'arriverait danané man est gay mais je
répétais que je n'apporterai la femme de
son oncle était là aussi non elle a dit
elle ne sera pas d'accord fait lui
prendre les médicaments que nous avons
reçu hier ils m'ont attrapée et m'ont
retenu à ce moment-là l'oncle de mon
fiancé est entré ils ont fermé la porte
quand j'ai commencé à crier ils m'ont
bâillonné
ensuite ils m'ont déshabillé et m'ont
forcé à prendre le médicament
ils ne m'ont laissé repartir que 24
heures après la fausse couche
habits car une femme a été forcés de
marcher nu devant la foule et a ensuite
été battu les habitants la soupçonnaient
d'avoir tué un homme
[Musique]
regarde
le gouverneur de l'état vient de me
décorer de cette médaille à la ville de
lucknow récemment
madame vous êtes une personne
d'importance internationale qu'est ce
que vous faites ici alors je ne veux pas
parler devant la caméra
éteignez la sent pas de pâles les pas
une simple robin des bois qui défend les
intérêts des pauvres
elle entretient également excellentes
relations avec les autorités
on peut aller beaucoup plus loin avec
une requête juridique politique avec un
simple bâton au cours des deux derniers
mois en janvier et février
nous avons enregistré six cas de
violence à l'égard des femmes
trois quatre cas sont déjà au tribunal
et deux font toujours l'objet d'une
enquête
les hommes craignent désormais que si la
grèce des femmes ou des jeunes filles la
police réagira très vite les arrêtera et
lancera rapidement une affaire pénale
donc le nombre de cas de violence a
baissé sensiblement le plus souvent ce
sont des hommes qui commettent ces
crimes
les affaires que nous envoyons devant
les tribunaux sont contre des hommes je
ne peux conseiller qu'une chose aux
jeunes gens soyez prudent pour votre
sécurité
si une fille a l'impression que
quelqu'un la harcèle que quelqu'un l'a
prise pour cible ou si quelqu'un lui
envoie des messages désagréables
nous lui demandons d'appeler
immédiatement notre ligne d'assistance
au numéro 10 90 appeler ce numéro et
nous serons sur place rapidement au plus
elles sont prudentes plus elles seront
en sécurité
on pourrait croire que sont à de pâles
prend le parti de la femme dans
n'importe quel conflit
mais ce n'est pas le cas même dans le
cas du viol collectif à delhi qui semble
sans ambiguïté la chef du gang des saris
roses a su trouver une erreur de la
victime nous avons eu un terrible
scandale la faire il n'y a qu'à y a mais
dans ce cas la fille a commis une erreur
elle était dans un bus avec son petit
ami et il a commencé à mal se comporter
il y avait aussi beaucoup d'autres
hommes dans le bus et ils ont perdu le
contrôle d'eux mêmes
voilà ce qui est arrivé dans ce genre de
situation les filles devraient être plus
responsables pourquoi prendre un bus
avec son petit ami à minuit plutôt
qu'avec ses parents
c'était son erreur on mettra d'ailleurs
je suis revenu chez moi et j'y racontais
à ma famille tout ce qui m'était arrivé
mais ils ont commencé à me réprimandé ne
fait rien nous ne pouvons pas leur faire
la guerre
c'est vrai que nous ne pouvons pas parce
que nous sommes très pauvres ils sont
très riches ils ont tous voilà pourquoi
il faisait pression tout le temps mais
j'ai perdu mon bébé j'ai beaucoup pleuré
personne ne m'a soutenu à ce moment là
je me suis dit que ce serait
probablement mieux que je meurs je suis
sorti de la maison j'ai pris un bus
je pleurais tout le temps les autres
passagers m'ont demandé pourquoi je
pleurais je leur ai tout raconté
ils m'ont dit que sans pattes pâle et
d'ailés fille malheureuse comme moi
quand on s'appelle monde y va voir
sampat pal
elle explique aux femmes leurs droits je
les ai écoutés et je suis venu ici
j'ai découvert l'existence de sampat pal
les gens qui se trouvent dans une
situation difficile
vienne la voir et leurs problèmes sont
résolus je suis allé voir samba de pâles
et j'ai commencé à faire tout ce que je
pouvais pour l'aider pendant deux ans et
demi j'ai participé au combat qu'elle
menait elle me traite avec respect et
amitié
elle a commencé à comprendre que j'étais
quelqu'un de bien tyntec je lui ai posé
cette question de manière délicate après
lui avoir tout raconté en détail si
quelqu'un a battu la personne et la
chasser de sa maison celui qui a perdu
sa maison petit la récupérer ou pas elle
a répondu pourquoi pas si c'est conforme
à la loi nous la récupèreront sans aucun
doute si ce n'est pas légalement
possible alors nous ne la récupère rompt
pas
la décision doit être conforme à la loi
elle a tout de suite accepté de m'aider
nous sommes allés à bâchant n'da et le
chef de la police du département
bichonne doubi était juste à côté du
bureau
nous lui avons raconté mon histoire et
il a dit écoutez madame si vous attendez
un peu je vous ai des justice sera faite
et c'est vrai quand les pauvres sont
victimes d'injustice
elles aident à rendre justice regardez
moi par exemple
quarante ans plus tard elle a mis
seulement 40 minutes pour trouver un
accord elle a tout expliqué et tout le
monde a tout compris et j'ai enfin pu
récupérer mon du jour commun quel est
ton ritoo dit lui comme ça je m'appelle
je m'appelle ritoo dis lui que tu
t'appelles rittaud aux habitudes
j'habite à pattaya et tu membres du gang
des saris roses
oui je vis avec les membres du gang des
saris roses
il me donne à manger je n'ai rien à
manger je vais dans la jungle pour
chercher du bois mort
je n'ai pas de logement tout ce qu'elle
dit est vrai quand j'arrive à vendre
quelque chose je peux manger on y
regarde moi tu me connais oui quel est
mon nom sans bas de page wissant pas de
balle maintenant dix mois ma fille
pourquoi tu ne fais pas des études il
n'y a pas d'école pas d'école et les
écoles qui se trouve plus loin elles ne
sont pas venues pas bonne
[Musique]
même l'école n'est pas toujours un
endroit très sûr une femme était restée
dans une des écoles du rajasthan déserte
cependant le confinement les hommes ont
fait irruption pendant la nuit et l'ont
violé pour les indiennes le combat au
bâton est un vrai cours d'autodéfense
qui leur redonne confiance en elle
si vous voyez une fille en sari rose
avec un bâton elle fait sûrement partie
du gang des saris roses et celui qui lui
fera du bal aura à faire à sa chef
[Musique]
beaucoup de choses ont changé notre
couleur rose est apparu sur la carte de
l'inde par exemple dans les états
d'hyderabad du tamil nadu de rhissa du
pendjab du karnataka dans beaucoup
d'endroits différents
des gens nous cherche via google et on
peut y trouver un numéro de téléphone
toutes les femmes qui ont des questions
et des problèmes m'appelle et je les
aide
si j'ai de bonnes informations
je peux même organisé deux rencontres et
rendre justice
je leur serai reconnaissant toute ma vie
si je peux faire quelque chose pour elle
je le ferai évidemment sans pales si je
suis en vie c'est seulement grâce à elle
j'ai déjà puni et je continue de punir
les gens qui m'ont fait du mal et tout
cela grâce à elle si je ne l'avais pas
rencontrée je serai peut-être déjà morte
et je n'aurais pas pu punir ces
criminels nous sommes fortes et le
resteront toujours je rendrai les femmes
du gang de saris roses courageuse les
saris roses pour toujours les saris
roses pour toujours la force d'une
famille c'est la dame la force d'un pays
c'est la femme pour le respect
[Musique]